EACH PERSON.
NOW ONTO THE BIG NEWS OF THE
DAY, AS YOU MIGHT HAVE HEARD,
KIRSTJEN NIELSEN IS OUT AS A
HOMELAND SECURITY SECRETARY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP DOUBLES DOWN ON
THIS CRACKDOWN AT THE BORDER.
U.S. CUSTOMS AND BORDER
PROTECTION KEVIN MCALEENAN WILL
BECOME THE ACTING SECRETARY.
THE PRESENT REPORTING A MASSIVE
OVERHAUL TO FIX THE CRISIS.
"MORE APPREHENSIONS, CAPTURES AT
THE SOUTHERN BORDER THAT IN MANY
YEARS.
BORDER PATROL AMAZING!
COUNTRY IS FULL!
SYSTEM HAS BEEN BROKEN
FOR MANY YEARS.
DEMOCRATS IN CONGRESS MUST AGREE
TO FIX LOOPHOLES.
NO OPEN BORDERS
CRIMES AND DRUGS.
WILL CLOSE SOUTHERN BORDER
IF NECESSARY."
>> FOR THE REST OF HER LIFE,
PEOPLE WILL LOOK AT HER AND
THINK THAT'S THE WOMAN WHO PUT
CHILDREN IN CAGES.
THAT'S THE WOMAN WHO BROKE UP
FAMILIES ACROSS THE BORDER.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
THEY WILL BE RIGHT.
>> SHE HAS BEEN A DISGRACE AS
SECRETARY OF HOMELAND SECURITY
SHE WAS BEHIND THE LEGACY OF
SEPARATING FAMILIES, CAGING
CHILDREN.
>> YOU ALMOST HAVE TO FEEL SORRY
FOR NIELSEN.
I DON'T FEEL SORRY FOR HER BUT
ALMOST.
SHE IS GOING TO VIOLATE THE
DICTATES OF HUMANITY, MORALITY
ON OTHERS BUT SHE'S NOT WILLING
TO BREAK THE LAW.
>> KIRSTJEN NIELSEN WILL BE
KNOWN FOR IMPLEMENTING ACCRUAL
POLICY OF FORCIBLY SEPARATING
PARENTS AND CHILDREN.
>> Dana: WHITE HOUSE TEMPORARY
PRESS SECRETARY SAYS --
>> I FIND IT INTERESTING THAT
THE MEDIA IS SO FOCUSED ON WHAT
HAPPENED BEHIND THE SCENES WITH
THE RESIGNATION OF SECRETARY
NIELSEN INSTEAD OF WORRYING
ABOUT WHAT'S ACTUALLY HAPPENING
AT THE BORDER.
WE HAVE A CRISIS DOWN THERE, AND
EMERGENCY IN THE MEDIA REFUSES
TO FOCUS ON IT BUT INSTEAD WANTS
TO TALK ABOUT PALACE INTRIGUE.
>> Dana: MICK MULVANEY
DOUBLING DOWN ON THE CRITICISM
OF DEMOCRATS HANDLING OF
IMMIGRATION.
>> I KNOW IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE
BUT NANCY PELOSI RUNS THE
DEMOCRATS IN CONGRESS, MEXICO
HAS DONE MORE IN THE LAST WEEK
TO HELP OUR ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION
CRISIS THEN NANCY PELOSI AND
DEMOCRATS IN THE HOUSE.
>> Dana: WE ARE GOING TO TAKE
IT AROUND THE TABLE.
GOING TO START WITH YOU, GREG.
>> Greg: I FIND IT RICHLY
IRONIC WHEN JEFF EACH HAVE BEEN
ACCUSES ANYBODY OF BREAKING UP
FAMILIES.
LET'S REMEMBER WHERE THAT STORY
STARTED WITH THOSE PICTURES
FIRST CAME OUT IN THE MEDIA, ON
TWITTER.
THOSE WERE PICTURES THAT WERE
FROM THE TIME WHEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS PRESIDENT.
THIS WAS A PROBLEM, SPLITTING UP
OF FAMILIES, IT WAS SHARED BY
BOTH FAMILIES.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME IN
PROBABLY RECENT HISTORY THAT WE
HAVE A NONPOLITICIAN TRYING TO
SOLVE A PROBLEM THAT WAS SHARED
BY BOTH PARTIES.
WE CAN AGREE THIS IS THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS.
YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT TRUMP AS A
GENERAL MANAGER OF A SPORTS
TEAM.
SITUATIONS NOT DICTATED BY THE
PLAYERS.
THE PLAYERS ARE DICTATED BY THE
SITUATION, SO WHEN THE SITUATION
REQUIRES A FIX, HE REPLACES
PEOPLE TO AFFECT THE SITUATION.
IT'S LIKE BASEBALL.
IF THE CURRENT LINEUP ISN'T
WORKING, YOU SAY -- HE BENCHED
THE GUY OR GET RID OF THE GUY,
TRADE THE GUY.
THAT'S ALL HE DOES.
HE SEES IF IT WORKS.
I SAID THIS BEFORE.
THE PERSON WHO TAKES THE
LONG-TERM SOLUTION WILL NEVER BE
TREATED SYMPATHETICALLY.
LONG-TERM SOLUTIONS ARE ALWAYS
HARSH IN THE SHORT TERM.
THE MEDIA ARE THE CHILDREN WHO
WANT ICE CREAM FOR BREAKFAST.
TRUMP IS THE PARENT SAY NO, YOU
KNOW WHAT.
TO BE A HEALTHY ADULT COMMUTER
GOING TO HAVE TO EAT LIKE THIS.
EAT YOUR GREENS.
WHAT TRUMP IS TRYING TO DO IS
AFFECT THE LONG-TERM SOLUTION
THAT WILL REMAIN THAT WAY AFTER
HE'S OUT OF OFFICE KNOWING THAT
HE'S SACRIFICING SO MUCH
CAPITAL.
EVERYBODY HATES HIM FOR BEING
THE PARENT.
THE MEDIA ESPECIALLY, BECAUSE
THEY ARE THE CHILDREN.
THE CHILDREN WHO BASICALLY PUSH
THE SLIDE THAT THIS WAS THE
FIRST ADMINISTRATION TO SEPARATE
FAMILIES.
>> Juan: IT IS THE TRUTH.
>> Greg: YOU REMEMBER THOSE
PICTURES?
>> Juan: HANG ON.
OBAMA WAS DEALING WITH
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS.
HERE YOU HAD FAMILIES.
MOMS AND CHILDREN SEPARATED BY
NIELSEN.
>> Greg: AND WHY?
>> Juan: NOT ONLY IS IT
ILLEGAL AND UNETHICAL AND
IMMORAL.
I AM SAYING --
IT'S JUST NOT TRUE WHAT YOU SAI
SAID.
>> Greg: IT WAS WORKING.
>> Juan: IT WASN'T WORKING.
WE HAVE A DIFFERENT KIND OF
ISSUE NOT WITH SO MANY FAMILIES
AND CHILDREN WITH THEIR
FAMILIES.
>> Greg: WHY?
>> Juan: I JUST WANT TO SAY,
DOES ALL THAT HE'S DONE MAKE YOU
FEEL SAFER?
GETTING RID OF NIELSEN, GETTING
RID OF THE SECRET SERVICE.
IT SEEMS TO ME THIS IS SO
DANGEROUS IN TERMS OF OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY.
WE SAW TODAY FROM THE BRAIN ROOM
THIS GUY HAS MORE CABINET
POSITIONS GONE THAN ANYBODY
GOING WAY BACK.
>> Dana: STICKING ON
IMMIGRATION, KATIE, YOUR
THOUGHTS.
KIRSTJEN NIELSEN IN SOME WAYS
WAS IN AN IMPOSSIBLE SITUATION.
SHE IS CONFINED BY THE LAW.
A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T LIKE A LOT
BUT CONGRESS WON'T FIX THE LAW
SO SHE WASN'T ABLE TO BE TOUGHER
IN THE WAY HE WANTED TO.
>> Katie: THIS HAS BEEN A LONG
TIME COMING.
IT'S NOT SOME RASH DECISION.
KIRSTJEN NIELSEN HAS BEEN ON THE
ROCKS FOR A LONG TIME WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP HERE SHE HAS
BEEN ABLE TO SOLIDIFY HER
POSITION FOR A COUPLE MONTHS BUT
THIS WAS INEVITABLY GOING TO
COME.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT FOR ANY
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
SECRETARY TO DO ANYTHING THAT
THEY ARE DOING MORE DUE TO THE
WAY THE SYSTEM IS SET UP.
THERE IS HOPE FOR McALEENAN
BECAUSE HE HAS A GOOD
RELATIONSHIP WITH PEOPLE ON
CAPITOL HILL.
HE WORKED FOR BARACK OBAMA AND
WAS ON THE FRONT LINES IN THIS
CRISIS WHEN IT STARTED IN 2015.
THE PHOTOS THAT EVERYONE SAID
BELONGED TO THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT CHILDREN
BEING IN CAGES, THOSE WERE FROM
2014 AND WE AT TOWN HALL AND AT
BREITBART, SOME OF THE ONLY
REPORTERS IN THE ENTIRE MEDIA
WHO WERE PUBLISHING THOSE PHOTOS
AND WARNING ABOUT THE CRISIS
THAT WAS COMING.
McALEENAN HAS SEEN THIS FROM
THE BEGINNING.
HE KNOWS WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE
AND HOPEFULLY CAN WORK WITH
COMMITTEES LIKE THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WHERE THE
ATTORNEYS THERE ARE WORKING ON
IMMIGRATION THEN THEY KNOW WHAT
NEEDS TO BE FIXED SO THEY
CONNECTION, WAS SOMETHING TO
CHANGE IT.
ONE MORE THING, THESE DEMOCRATS
TALKING ABOUT HOW HORRIBLE
KIRSTJEN NIELSEN WAS, THAT SHE
WAS A TERRIBLE PERSON FOR
SEPARATING PARENTS AND CHILDREN.
IF YOU BREAK THE LAW IN AMERICA
AND BREAK -- GO TO PRISON, YOU
ARE SEPARATED FROM YOUR
CHILDREN.
THEY ARE NOT PUTTING ANY
LEGISLATION ON THE TABLE DOES
SOLVE THE PROBLEM WHICH SETS UP
THE TALKING POINT FOR THEM FOR
YEARS TO COME WHEN YOU ARE
SAYING THESE CHILDREN WERE
BROUGHT HERE BY THEIR PARENTS
ILLEGALLY.
SHOULD WE HAVE A DREAM OR
PROGRAM FOR THEM AS WELL?
A WHOLE NOTHER SYSTEM THEY ARE
SETTING UP.
>> Dana: JESSE, AND THE TIME
HAVE REMAINING, WE GIVE YOU THE
FLOOR.
>> Jesse: AMERICA, GREATEST
COUNTRY IN THE FACE OF THE
EARTH.
CAN'T STOP FOREIGNERS FROM
COMING HERE AND STAYING HERE
BECAUSE OF DUMB LAWS AND DUMBER
POLITICIANS.
WE ARE ERASING OUR OWN BORDERS
OURSELVES.
WHO YOU THINK ABOUT IT, PERSON
AND CENTRAL AMERICA, GRAB A KID,
SET FOOT -- SET 1 FOOT IN TEXAS
AND WE CAN'T DO ANYTHING ABOUT
IT.
YOUR KID, WHOEVER YOU ARE
BRINGING, THEY ARE A DREAMER.
THEY ARE GOING TO BE SUBSTANCE.
YOU GO TO CALIFORNIA.
YOU'RE GOING TO GET WELFARE,
DRIVER'S LICENSE, HEALTH CARE.
COMMIT A FELONY, NO ONE IS GOING
TO DEPORT YOU.
YOU CAN DO WHATEVER YOU WANT.
THE DEMOCRATS WANT THIS
SITUATION.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT FAMILIES
BEING SEPARATED.
IF THEY DID, THEY WOULD DO
SOMETHING TO FIX IT.
PELOSI HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
HERSELF WHEN SHE CUT THE DEAL
WITH TRUMP LAST MONTH.
DID SHE OFFER AN ASYLUM FIX, A
DETENTION FIX?
SHE OFFERED LITERALLY NOTHING
EXCEPT A FEW WARM BEDS.
WHEN THE DEMOCRATS TALK, DON'T
LISTEN TO THEM.
I DON'T EVEN HEAR WHAT THEY ARE
SAYING.
LOOK WHAT THEY ARE DOING, AND
THEY ARE ABSOLUTELY DOING
NOTHING.
>> Katie: AND THEN THEY TRIED
TO CUT THE NUMBER OF BEDS.
>> Juan: TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT
THE REPUBLICANS, WHAT TRUMP IS
DOING, SEEMS TO ME THAT WHATEVER
TRUMP RUNS INTO A CONFLICT
SITUATION, YOU HAVE A SIMPLE
SOLUTION AND HE DECIDES HE WANTS
TO GO BEYOND THE LAW.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED WITH
KIRSTJEN NIELSEN.
SHE WENT IN THERE YESTERDAY
AFTERNOON AT 5:00.
SHE DIDN'T INTEND TO RESIGN AND
HE IS TELLING HER TO STOP PEOPLE
FROM APPLYING FOR ASYLUM.
KICK PEOPLE OUT.
GET RID OF THE JUDGES.
GET RID OF THE JUDGES?
WOW.
>> Jesse: YOU DON'T HAVE
SOLUTIONS.
YOUR PARTY HAS NO SOLUTIONS.
>> Juan: THAT'S NOT TRUE.